hey guys I'm back with another video a
very short video on roasted seaweed
someone want to know my opinion on
roasted seaweed I think it's great
they're tasty little dehydrated wafers
of seaweed that provide a good amount of
nutrition now I'm always recommending
seafood and shellfish but seaweed is
another great product syria is a plant
vegetable that can extract the minerals
from the seawater and pull them into the
plant then you consume the plant because
the plant actually converted those
elemental minerals into a form of
minerals that are very easy to
assimilate so the benefit of seaweed
would be the trace minerals that's the
big benefit especially we iodine
selenium zinc and iron but there's
actually a total of 84 iodine is good
for the thyroid but it's also good to
help buffer excessive amounts of
estrogen many people are estrogen
dominant and also a lot of chemicals in
the environment pesticides insecticides
herbicides heavy metals have the
capacity to mimic estrogen so they're
called
estrogen or endocrine disruptors iodine
especially the form that comes in
seaweed can help counter that effect and
then we have selenium I've done videos
on this lynnium is incredible for
autoimmune conditions like Hashimoto's
with a hypothyroid condition it's it's a
real powerful antioxidant it helps
counter heavy metals especially mercury
and it does a lot of other things as
well selenium it's involved in over to a
thousand enzymes it's a really important
in digestion brain function supporting
testosterone then we have iron that
fortified your red blood cells but also
there's a potassium calcium magnesium
manganese chromium there's a lot of
other minerals involved now we have
vitamins vitamin C the B vitamins
full-length there's amino acids in
seaweed and also it has DHA and EPA
which if you're a vegetarian this would
be a good source and DHA and EPA our
omega-3 fatty
it's now if you're consuming something
like flaxseed or walnuts you're getting
the precursor for these two called ala
but with seaweed you can actually get
DHA and EPA directly so it doesn't have
to converge now if you're concerned
about heavy metals because maybe the
source of the seaweed is in a polluted
ocean finest EVD comes from a clean
environment an organic version would be
great so to summarize this is a great
way to get your trace minerals and other
nutrients and if you have a small child
you can give them some of this but just
don't give them a lot because this does
have a concentrated amounts of these
minerals especially iodine so a little
bit would be fine anyway that's my
opinion and thanks for watching if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos